well it can't be against in the funniest
way on the city of city of cambridge
side we have wonderful former city
councillor and Mayor Alva Lucci who was
my mentor who he was a big idea guy will
home that although he didn't graduate
from high school until he was well up in
his 60s he went to Community Learning
Center and got a GED but I'll like to be
kind of a prankster and a trickster with
Harvard and with MIT so he would
threaten at various times to pave over
Harvard Square or Harvard Yard you know
they should pay taxes and he would kind
of have his own critiquing and that way
he exercised a fair amount of influence
with Harvard particularly with MIT he
kind of got into this interesting
question about what what exactly are
they doing in all these labs and
particularly the labs with animals or
and are they are they are petri dishes
producing three-headed people or that
kind of thing and of course the
scientific community community got a
little concerned that you know nobody
has really asked this but L in an
attempt to answer his own question he
got involved with understanding about
the National Institutes of Health and
how much money they give for research
and how much disproportionately MIT gets
and so I can't take exactly how he made
this leap but he got the Cambridge City
Council to adopt the research standards
produced by the National Institutes of
Health and this really gave scientists
both here and from elsewhere the first
place that they knew what the rules were
and this began to attract various
researchers here and endrin company
and then mit literally is a very
intimate relationship with the National
Institutes of Health and they I said
before disproportionally received
funding that way and in fact in my team
determines how many graduate students
it's going to have in the sciences
largely based on what the research
funding is from NIH and then that
research often walks across the street
to a for-profit company founded by the
MIT professor who worked on the NIH
grant and it turns out that this is very
much in the DNA of MIT at Harvard it
would just be unthinkable prior to now
Harvard has changes thinking that you
would mix for-profit science with pure
sighs well at MIT that's been good
always and hence it really is in the DNA
here and so that has caused so many
different companies to be spun off from
work done at MIT